i don't like obscenities just as much as
you don't like oh it drives me crazy i
have kids right but i've got my little
three-year-old i'm going through the
park and someone's like hey mike
the guys my
head
i was born ready
ron swanson am i the only person here
who doesn't know janine restrepo
that woman is tough
in 1994 i gave her a nickname it's
unrepeatable but it stuck
it's my proudest accomplishment
it's the iron
of pawnee i want to take you both home
and
bend you over and just
at the same time kyle i'm gonna lose my
on you if you asked me one more time
this check is made out to go yourself in
your fa
the [ __ ] is a german muffin
well i'm sorry to burst your kabubble
but i just had my ass handed to me by
the city manager and now this entire
department is co-screwed
ron i'm so so sorry
what the
were you thinking
ron i'm sorry but this can't wait
jessica wicks refuses leslie what the
get some sleep aye aye captain
i got a second box of donuts if anybody
what the is this
i can smell your dreams tom
i can't
and i can smell them from here
and honestly they smell
terrible your dad bro comes at him
swayze tucks scissor kick slime the guy
has to squeeze his head and he says i
used to guys like you in prison
i'm just glad you didn't end up inviting
more of the motor
what the hell give me some warning what
religion am i
well i'm a practicing none of your
business
that's [ __ ]
hey what about you mr uh a man's word is
sacred well it is but you're an ass
the point is my mom is alive and i love
her she's one tough cookie
that's why everybody calls her the
iron
pawnee
fondly
greg pochitis
would you like some boiling hot coffee
your face
my name is bert macklin
yeah i'm with the
fbi
what the [ __ ] man lil sebastian
are you
kidding me
you got little sebastian same for
yourself
oh that's really dangerous please tell
me this is going to be so fun letting
you dangle until i finally reveal that
we did not make out
oh
damn it
what
three two
one and my shift's over what the [ __ ] is
your problem so you have two choices one
get rid of tammy or two lobotomy and
castration
choose wisely
stupid
don't you ever [ __ ] me like that again
this is pawnee
today you know i guess i've been
mispronouncing your name all these years
mark brandana quits
recently i had been thinking about maybe
uh leaving this job but i felt like i
needed a sign
and then ann broke up with me the week
that i was gonna propose
the government got shut down and
yesterday
one of those pigeons took on me
fine i'll let you off the leash
andy
dude where'd you come from
please
give me one reason to take you down i
would love nothing
oh
ben sorry all right let's go
why are you laughing because my dream is
dead
[Laughter]
barbecue should be about one thing
good shared meat
there will be no froofy desserts there
will be no giant soap bubble guns there
will be no adult men in costumes and
most of all
there will be no
vegetables so you're not pregnant this
isn't yours no
i'm gonna go choke down those horse
pills i have to take every day oh no no
i'll cut them in half for you and i will
pour you a glass of flaxseed milk to
wash it down everything is amazing today
is perfect
and i love you
chris is so wonderful and thoughtful and
positive
he's driving me up the wall smoothie's
ready
how much postage does it take to send a
letter to canada who's it going to
canada
it says dear canada
you
in the name of unity i have given some
former eagletonians the first strike
take it away guys
such a great day for
peace
oh man this is amazing man the stupid
eagletonians are totally getting pwned
by these bees we'll send this straight
to tash
[Applause]
[Music]
oh look john it's red pine
they were gonna put flecked linoleum
over this beautifully preserved naughty
red pine most people in this world john
are asked
and you have an office mate his name is
stuart and he's kind of a grouch i have
an office mate get these balloons out of
here and special thanks to leslie knope
for once again bringing about positive
change to this town pawnee i present to
you
your new slogan
you fixed the mistakes well i held it
together for the entire meeting let me
have this one i am done micromanaging i
promise
then i'm sure you're okay with the fact
that they installed the sign the wrong
way and it's welcoming you to pawnee as
you're leaving
what
no oh son of a
andy
what is happening right now
i thought you were serious come on now
you know i don't give a
and hey you may be old you'll never be
as old as me
yeah
you're oldest
thanks ben
glad i could help the word bistro is
classy
oh man this wine ball is all out of the
wine oh hello gentlemen
what brings you out on this fine evening
mother
but leslie hid the location of our
valentine's meeting place in here no
tried every five-letter word that has
anything to do with our third date
have you tried
did you try
the numbers got a lot higher i think i
heard the computer laugh at me and
saperstein wants us to relax are you
ready to go my gentle dove oh i will be
there in two flaps of a butterfly's wing
and i love you
we are so
screwed
someone tell me what neb campbell sounds
like i will now extinguish this candle
with my bare hand okay
i'm ron swanson
and you're leslie
knope does the white whale actually
symbolize the unknowability and
meaninglessness of human existence
yeah no it's just a fish
in addition to governor knope's honorary
doctorate from the school of public
policy in recognition of all she's done
for the people of indiana
the campus library will henceforth bear
her name
[Applause]
holy
we are responsible adults
you know what that means i know we have
money and we are going to buy the
out of this house seriously yes who
needs rental insurance we're gonna live
here
beef milk
it's like almond milk that's been
squeezed through tiny holes in living
cows
milk i'm being held as a prisoner
against my will and i have the right as
a citizen of the united states to blow a
hole in that
door and walk out as a free man it's in
the constitution there's no cursing in
the constitution but so much is changing
and i've never been a fan of change
salvatore
was a constant in my life in my
experience the only constant is change
you